[Music]
in Alva
oh Pearl welcome welcome come on in
Stockholm syndrome okay do you say
Stockholm syndrome do you understand the
concept
well that's not where you fall in love
with an abuser uh coerce people do you
tell people to do things that they do
not want to do I mean I say
set up the camera
can you get my mic
Monday
controlling and uh it is something that
is am I paying for this the first
session is for burning from now on uh it
will be 500 pounds a minute like I said
we've got 25 sessions on the books for
now how do you rate yourself out of 10
what would you say
five
if you love yourself you will know that
you are a 10 out of 10 girl and is that
why you have not yet started your only
fans page I am feeling like an emotional
revolutionary ready to change lives
inspire people and put them on a better
emotional path with more maturity and
Light
you know I'm feeling good the internet
keeps saying that I need therapy so
I decided why not give it a shot I have
an open mind you know I always said no
no they're a piece bad you know it's all
crazy ladies but I was like you know
what hurl you can come in with an open
mind well we'll learn the truth about
herself you know she will find herself
within herself and just love herself she
will be herself
my ideal therapist would be a guy women
therapists are usually insane
um they usually make your problems worse
and they they act like you have all this
trauma and emotional abuse or blah blah
blah so ideally it would be a nice older
man that really could give me like
fatherly advice or just like very stoic
and wise I mean I have four sisters you
know I've got a lot of girlfriends I
give them a lot of advice I'm uh I'm
smart you know I'm a freelance therapist
really no qualification but a lot of
knowledge and wisdom well I don't know I
don't know don't they like find the
problems for you I mean I look it I live
a great life I I had an awesome
childhood now I'm here I'm doing awesome
life is awesome but the internet keeps
saying that I need this therapy and you
know now all the women are coming out
and they have they have this emotional
abuse so I say
um well if the bar for emotional abuse
is yelling then maybe I just have trauma
and emotional abuse because everyone
everyone's been emotionally abused so
you know I guess
solve my my trauma these women will come
in they'll say I need therapy and then
they'll bully me you know it's like
they'll attack my face which I can't
help they'll say I don't dress well
they'll go after my family they'll
they'll
um contact they'll they'll contact my
ex-boyfriend they'll harass me online
they'll call me a grifter they'll call
me like whatever they want to call me
they'll just they just call me names
they'll call me ugly stupid
and I just think to myself well I didn't
eat therapy before but maybe I do now uh
I will give her this because I believe
in my services and I know this is going
to be revolutionary for Poe I'm giving
her this as a pro berno and then from
here on Fourth it's going to be 500
pounds per minute I'm ready I'm ready
for I'm right I'm ready to heal my
trauma
in Alva
oh Pearl welcome welcome come on in take
a seat make yourself comfortable I hope
that you are ready to change your life
[Music]
very good welcome okay so I walk in and
not only did they give me a female
therapist
[Music]
they gave me denalva
in Alva and I go way back and now that
is the craziest woman I know and they
have given me her for therapy
for therapy and this is what I mean you
go to therapy they make you crazier now
I'll have an open mind maybe denalva has
all these credentials and she really
knows how to you know give you a better
life but I I see this as going poorly uh
I'd like to say it's very brave of you
to take this step into you know finding
the solution to finding your true self
and coming to
coming to an acceptance of who you truly
are so please make yourself comfortable
it's okay if you are any point need a
tissue you know we can get really
emotional you might feel teary tissue
yes
basically I'm very good at that about
what I do so Pearl how are you feeling
today tell me
um
surprised I'll just say surprise
surprise okay
I'm sure
okay and um this is a very simple
process I my job here is not to tell you
any judgments or put any pressure on you
I'm simply here to guide you through a
conversation that will ultimately get
you to understand who you truly are to
accept yourself to be comfortable in
your shoes and to understand your
traumas and how to make traumas
we all have them darling it's but it's
part of Being Human so it's very simple
let me just start with a few questions
about where usually all begins your
childhood tell me about your childhood
so I had nine siblings
um when I was growing up there were six
in the house I was the second oldest
okay two married parents
um they had a software company
life was good I played a lot of
volleyball I did I did good
okay so obviously in the house with a
lot of a lot of people and parents that
together at times that I'm sure it must
be so difficult for you to express
yourself and have emotional support
sometimes with so many people around you
no
it's pretty easy in denial
it was did you say I was in denial
don't worry these are just notes for
myself okay well yeah no I liked it it
was good good childhood
okay are you sure yeah okay
um you say you played a lot of sport
how did that affect your femininity
maybe a bit of a tomboy yeah tomboy okay
um do you have any issues with
identifying yourself what is your
pronoun Pearl
did you ask me what my pronoun is
I'm a woman
okay sorry
um I'm a woman
okay
needs
to come to grips
okay and um oh tell me
is your relationship like
um good yeah my my dad I always talk
about he's like the best
person I know on the planet ever
my mom's also awesome you know she's
been on the channel a couple times but
the internet kind of comes after them
sometimes which is a bit
so I kind of I've stopped putting them
on as much but they're both awesome
people you know I don't know anyone
better than my parents
um it may just be that that you hear you
may be
expressing a slight unrealistic reality
of your relationship with your parents
an unrealistic reality so why do you ask
me questions if you don't think my
answers are real
like I told you I'm here to guide you
all right and to help you to find
yourself in your true truth and your
true life bro
um do you think that your relationship
with your father may have given you
unrealistic expectations of men
now I just expect they're not going to
be as good as him
okay because most people aren't as good
as him my dad's just a very nice human
um okay I'm around my dad I just want to
be a better person they like it it's
inspiring actually so no I mean my dad
always told me to actually have like no
expectations of anybody okay he said
expect the worst and if they impress you
then be happy
um it seems like you know that's a voice
and presence in your life is quite
important and I think that perhaps for
the next session uh we should
potentially consider exploring uh what
we call in a professional field daddy
issues
I think it might be something worth us
looking at but we'll go into more detail
about this daddy issues because I said
my dad was awesome uh don't worry Paul
we'll go into that it's no need to feel
nervous and defensive I do know that
this can be a triggery moment and
process I mean I just don't understand
it's like
okay what is this therapy session it's
okay you just need to be open-minded ex
just accept me all right okay I'm
accepting yes okay therapy totally makes
you uh it helps it helps it helps you to
find your true self okay and tell me
about your relationship with your mother
what what is that like my my mom growing
up
um would pick me up from practice we'd
listen to country songs on the way back
my mom
um she she's a really nice woman you
know she's really kind caring
um she adopted three kids so that takes
a really nice kind caring person okay
all right this is good you have a
powerful mother figure uh did your
mother work
um she worked for my dad yeah they they
work together
okay so they had what we would call an
unhealthy dependent relationship
would you agree with that wait
okay it's married people
have an unhealthy dependent relationship
on each other
okay well I think that you know do you
need a tissue
is that you know your stress levels I
can sense your energy and no no no I
just yeah not not nervous just a little
a little confused how that makes sense
open-minded open-mindedness that's the
key to this okay yeah yeah so you've got
what you described as a good
relationship with your mother
um is your mother somebody that you can
speak to do you feel like this because
you mentioned your father somebody you
can go to it by your mother yeah if I
have a if I have a problem I can go to
my mom or my dad I'm very lucky you're
very lucky you talk about your problems
a lot
do I talk about my problems a lot I mean
I'm a woman we always whine
okay is exhibiting early signs of
potential anxiety slash
mental
has to accept
happiness and positivity okay
um I think that obviously I can tell by
your reaction to my questions that
family might be a really touchy subject
for us to speak on so we'll unfold this
one on our following session obviously
um after this I'm looking to book
another maybe five sessions with you for
you to really get the full benefit of
the experience
um let's leave your family for now let's
leave your family let's move forward
let's move forward to your high school
you said you played sport correct I did
uh did you have friends
dead
okay what were your friends like
um
they were good I I was friends with um
two friends were like my best friends in
high school I hung out with them a lot
and then I just had different friends
like cure there you know okay so maybe I
played a lot of sports so I might have
had a couple on one team a couple on
another
um I think I did some clubs too I don't
remember what but yeah life was good
do you believe that you may have used
sport as a way to
you know have friends
did I use sport as a way to have friends
yes
I mean
I made friends through Sports
okay in denial of Need for acceptance of
other people using sport as a tool to
achieve friendships I went into sports
because my parents enrolled me in sports
and I liked it now did I did I make
friends through Sports sure
um and what if I did so what this is
what these crazy ladies do they make
something into nothing okay let's say I
I I started Sports to make friends is
that a bad thing
is that is that is that wrong
but no I started I played basketball
when I was like seven well I was making
decisions at seven no my parents put me
in it
okay
um this is this is great you're doing
very well Pearl
um
I heard mom I read on your profile that
uh because of your insatiable need to
have validation and receive attention
from people and to be able to make
friends you are labeled as a pygmy is
that correct
yeah yeah they label me as a pygmy okay
so obviously you do not get enough
attention and why do you think people
call you pick me
they're idiots
okay aggression
okay and why do you think they are
idiots for calling your pick me
um because it's usually if I say
something they don't like they get
they'll say oh she's just saying that
because she wants to get picked but
really
they're just kind of dumb like they
can't they can't think about what I'm
saying I'll give you an example
I say hey
fat chicks are fat
and they get mad at me but I mean what
did you they're fat okay and and how
does that make you feel
to say those things or when they call me
that
place
um
I cry myself to sleep every night just
thinking about how much they just get to
me
just kidding
um no I think I think they're idiots I
think they're dummies I think you know
um
I don't really care it doesn't affect me
the internet land
avoidance deficit okay avoidance deficit
sometimes it's natural for us to you
know run away from the truth for for us
to run away from how we feel about how
other people feel towards us
um is there a potential chance that at
times you have a safe
self-hate you talk to yourself in a
negative light
do I have do I have self-hate yes I mean
I mean let me explain this question do I
have self-hate yes
um I think there's qualities about
yourself that you like yes and you don't
like
um so are there things about myself I
dislike yeah but other things about
myself that I like okay yeah
um so if I were to ask you
how do you rate yourself out of 10
what would you say
like a five
okay do you do you understand that that
how that is an unrealistic and an
insecure expression of how you feel how
you view yourself because I think I'm
average
if you love yourself you will know that
you are a 10 out of 10 Pearl this is
very concerning I think that you're
unrealistic Judgment of yourself so I
should I should rate myself a 10. yes
uh and that is the reason why I must
conclude that you also need to get some
work done and we need to have a
conversation about self-hate because you
must not really like yourself a lot
um I have also noticed
um you don't wear much makeup do you not
much no do you hate yourself because of
that do you hate your beauty
because I don't wear makeup you must be
insecure
why'd you know any makeup okay because I
have better things to do
okay it feels uncomfortable with loving
oneself okay no problem uh would you say
that you are an insecure person in
general
no no why that
why am I not insecure
um
because I think that the world labels
being realistic with insecurity
and I think most people have room for
improvement so
I mean I think the most insecure people
are the ones that rate themselves tens
put on a bunch of makeup
and talk about how awesome they are all
the time me on the other hand I just
think of a normal chick I think I'm good
at some stuff I think I'm bad at other
stuff
okay so do you believe that you may
perhaps be envious of the fact that
other people wear makeup and you must
present yourself in your natural form
no
denial it's very important for you pal
to be really honest to be very open and
to really Embrace The Experience so that
we can get to the truth in the bottom of
how how you've come to be here obviously
you must be distressed right now if you
need a tissue at any point do let me
know because we're about to get into
something I'm not I'm not distressed
okay it's okay calm down okay you are
I'm not I'm not you are fine this is a
safe I'm not I'm not even okay
patience shows a lot of signs
and self-hate okay uh Pearl
uh
I think that we need to discuss
something that nowadays is very much the
norm and I think the fact that you
oppose it may
it may indicate that you may have some
sort of social anxiety disorder and uh a
rebellion against wanting to fit in and
belong to society
um is that why you have not yet started
your only fans page
um
are you saying
that I don't I don't fit in because I
haven't started my only fans It is 2023.
Well I think that you have a very strong
desire to oppose uh progress to oppose
the norm to oppose the society that you
live in is that down to your self-hate
that you mentioned earlier
um
no
okay so why is it that you feel the need
to rebel against uh starting your own
only fans page
just I didn't really want to sell my ass
for 5.99 okay so you have some uh body
insecurities
don't doesn't everybody
okay
does anyone have a perfect body topic
um do you feel maybe afraid that you
might not make any money if you start
your only fans
could that be the reason what of why
you're holding yourself back from is it
hard to sell ass pictures
and let's try to stay away from avoiding
the the the question by asking questions
why is it that you have not started your
only fans
it just I didn't want to and why is that
um
better things to do okay
morals yes okay you know Daddy no Daddy
Issues so
you know having a dad in my life okay
so you have you here uh just to give you
some insight into my observation so far
um it's very important for you to start
recognizing within you that
um you may have a narcissistic outlook
on life
where you hide your insecurities through
thinking there's better things out there
okay wait and not wanting to fit in I'm
a narcissist
who hides my insecurities on life
by thinking I don't need to fit in
yes
um I mean
you must be right
is that why you hate fat people as well
um I don't hate fat people I just don't
like looking at them
okay is it because you may reflect
yourself on them
potentially
I mean no I I just don't like watching
the blubber like
okay I do understand what is your
relationship with food I mean I think we
need to delve into that it seems like it
may come from that space how I mean I
like food okay I like sugar sugar like
sweets okay
so you may also have a sugar induced
hyperactive mind uh
do you you just make a for a
living
so it's okay to you know be defensive
sometimes I do understand this is a very
difficult process to go through and
given everything that you have already
experienced with being online and having
all this attention that brought you all
the way to therapy to come and help
yourself and fix yourself I think that
it's really really important that you
know just embrace the process all right
my fault my fault okay Embrace I
apologize it's probably my narcissistic
Tendencies exactly and this is what
we're trying to fix here we're trying to
make you better so that you can be more
accepted and more loved by the world and
also by yourself uh pearl one thing that
concerns me a lot is yourself hate and
the lack of self-love and I need to
understand where this stems from
um Pearl I do understand that you had
been in a relationship that is being
brought up online very often
um do you feel upset for being exposed
for being a victim of obviously what
seems to be a very real and emotionally
this disturbing relationship
no it was it was fine it was fine okay
uh were you previously engaged to this
person I know that there's some videos
circulating around that indicate that
you may have been
no
okay it was like it was like we would
fake like videos like we would pretend
but it wasn't uh Pearl
uh
have you ever been emotionally
abused or disturbed uh
before
well I mean the bar for emotional abuse
is like freaking anything so I'll hear
I'll hear these women online say oh I
was emotionally abused and like what was
it oh he yelled at me I'm like
you've never been yelled at that's a mo
that's the bar for emotion or I'll see
oh I can't go to the club emotional
abuse oh you can't wear that emotional
abuse oh you can't do that emotional
abuse I'm like if this is emotional
abuse then I've been emotionally abused
I have just gone I've just gone through
all of this trauma that's all I hear
about yes that's all I hear about no
before what you have been told no before
everyone has someone has raised their
voice at you before
I mean I totaled my car when I was sick
or I didn't total it but I almost
totaled my car when I was 16 and yeah my
dad was pissed okay victim of
extensive and heightened emotional
disturbances
um well I'm really sorry to hear about
that I mean it's it's hard I deserved it
okay
and still suffers from Stockholm
syndrome okay do you say Stockholm
syndrome do you understand the concept
well it's not where you fall in love
with an abuser okay my deaf men
not every man I love my dad but he he
yelled at me because I crashed my car
okay I love my what's okay let me get
this straight
nobody grew up in a perfect family my
family wasn't perfect your family wasn't
perfect but am I gonna whine and cry
um because my dad yelled at me when I
was 16 because I don't know I crashed my
car let me get this straight you do
something stupid your dad yells at you
and you're a victim
maybe I shouldn't crash my car
diagnosis confirmed okay
um Pearl I'm sorry for uh knowing that
you went through this experience but it
does explain a lot why you hate yourself
and you struggle to uh to
to just be comfortable in who you are
and why you may have become a pygmy I
believe that this may be one of the
symptoms that comes with being
emotionally disturbed by people raising
their voice at you telling you no
disagreeing with you
I know it's very difficult and you don't
have to go through this you don't have
to accept that it's okay Pearl we will
find the solution to this problem as
well we will work through the Kinks of
this abuse and make you feel better more
healthy are you okay you seem a bit
disturbed would you like a tissue
no I'm okay it's okay you you it's okay
to cry this is one of the prescriptions
that I will give you
um after this session a little bit more
playing
okay okay okay
do Financial abuse okay
um
Pearl have you ever bought a man
anything in your life
yeah no I have okay
okay I bought
I buy it
a guy
I bought I bought an ex-boyfriend a nice
watch
oh okay
uh
that is very concerning as a woman
it was his birthday okay financially
exploited
by dependent
okay I was exploited
have you ever paid for a meal before
yeah further confirmation of diagnosis
okay and how did that make you feel
I mean I was hungry
okay Pearl no humid let's take this
seriously how do you feel about being
financially exploited uh by men
potentially by others uh when as a woman
you should never pay for anything at any
time any moment possible
I mean I guess if it was free that would
have been nice
he's just humor to avoid dealing with
her reality
um okay Pearl
do you still pay for things
yes okay
and
why do you pay for these things
is it because potentially you may have
an unhealthy relationship with people
the money given the fact that obviously
uh
you have heard a lot of people working
under you and from what online is
discussing you have also now reflected
how much you have been financially
exploited onto others is that correct
no
okay let's go
can you explain to why you've
financially exploited others
they say this is the best job they've
ever had
okay denial okay and uh how much did
they give you to be able to have this
job
no one no one gave me anything okay all
right that clears that up uh Financial
exploitation and financial boundaries is
something that potentially you may have
to discuss uh very soon uh yes you
wanted to say something
I'm just speechless
do you feel that at times you may uh
tell people what to do
I mean sometimes yeah I mean people work
for me okay so controlling and uh and
what does that look like do do you uh
coerce people do you tell people to do
things that they do not want to do I
mean I say
set up the camera
can you get my mic
demanding
um sometimes the intern gets coffee
okay also
has a royalty perception of herself
a royalty perception
um usually when people expect things
from other services from others such as
what you described
um it kind of
it it's something that is very new in
our field but is
um coercive exploitation of subordinates
oh oh oh oh
I am just such a controlling boss my
employees just have the worst time let
me get this straight let me get this
straight
um blessing would you do yesterday
oh he went to a wedding instead of
worked he went to a wedding now I don't
say this the point I point out they get
to work whenever they want
he comes and goes whenever he wants
he picks his own hours
I don't I don't tell him who to hire I
don't tell him who to Fire and I'm
controlling because sometimes I ask
they get me coffee
really a caramel latte
that's my that that's my controlling
Behavior hey set up the mics
I hired him to set up the mics
why is it a bad thing oh I want to set
up microphones
yeah we discussed this thing and I
shouldn't I can't tell anyone to do
anything no pearl no you shouldn't you
should not you should not pay for
anything oh so I have to do so every
time my dad's told me what to do or a
boyfriend's told me what to do then I've
been coerced you have been coerced and
you use a very fine line uh right okay
it's a very fine line it could be
coercion but also there are hints of
emotional disturbances and emotional
manipulation emotional manipulation yes
Pearl and do you believe that is that
something that uh you are drawn to
perhaps is that why emotionally
manipulate manipulated is that why you
have people working for you
so I can emotionally manipulate them
potentially I mean it is something that
is being discussed am I paying for this
the first session is pro bono from now
on uh it will be 500 pounds a minute
like I said we've got 25 sessions on the
books for now uh I'm prescribing you
that because I believe that you really
need this does this think I'm
gonna pay for this oh let me pay let me
pay oh let me let me pay to make myself
crazier let me pay money let me put
money out of my pocket that I work so
hard for
to become crazy
fantastic
um is there anything else that you've
heard about yourself online that has uh
potentially triggered you
triggered me yes
um
I usually stay pretty calm yeah
um I don't really like when sometimes
they'll go for my family and I I just
think that's a little bit too far
um
Maybe
I mean most of the stuff they say is
just like crazy talk okay so it's like
what do I care about crazy people think
okay so everyone is crazy but you okay
so do you feel the need to separate
yourself no no I didn't say everybody
was crazy I just I said a lot of the
comment sections crazy okay oh of course
I do understand hate is gonna hate us
they say uh Paul let's go back a little
bit let's talk about the attacks on your
family do you believe or
do you agree that your parents your
family your friends and the people
around you are responsible for who you
have become today
no
I I may be my parents but I would say
I'm responsible for my own decisions
okay
uh I think you may be running away from
the fat sometimes perhaps this is
another thing that we should probably
explore is the reason why people are
going to attack your family as they are
quite heavily responsible for who you
are and for that reason potentially you
might be in denial or not understanding
that it's not all about you
okay
um let's continue let's continue what
else what else does that even mean
uh it just means that perhaps you may
just not be understanding the world
around you and because you are
presenting some serious signs of
narcissistic disorder Pearl
so wait wait you want you wanna
diagnose me with narcissistic
personality disorder
after like 20 minutes and increase my
sessions
yes
and you want me to take this seriously
yes bro it's very important that you
take your health very seriously your
mental Fitness very seriously and that's
the purpose of this conversations that
we can understand what bothers you you
keep just you keep giving me issues
like now I say my childhood's good now
oh it's trauma
then I say oh my
you know my siblings great trauma
the comment section's crazy trauma yes
yes and you so what isn't trauma then
everything's trauma are you feeling okay
would you like a tissue I can tell that
you're feeling quite traumatized right
now for my conversation you are finally
understanding where your traumas and
where your issues are coming from
do you agree
no okay still in denial it's okay Pearl
I know this is a very new experience and
you know you need to get used to it it
doesn't just come overnight so we will
keep going into the depth of it what
else bothers you about your experience
as a very famous person online
probably the most famous pick me online
um what bothers me
not much I have a pretty good life I
mean
again I I don't
I mean sometimes they they say things
that aren't true about me and so
sometimes it's like
you have to spend all day
fighting a narrative that you didn't
make and how does that make you feel
I mean it's annoying sometimes they have
all these like theories about me they
psychoanalyze me they they make up all
these stories about me and
um
yeah I mean sometimes I wish they
wouldn't but I know it's part of the job
and I just deal with it okay so how many
nights a week do you cry yourself to
sleep
um I don't even remember the last time I
cried okay maybe
I like I can't even
maybe like six months ago five months
ago okay emotional suppression but it is
because they don't cry all the time yes
it is very unhealthy uh to suppress your
emotions obviously yeah why would I cry
if I have better stuff to do
okay still in denial it's not a good
um it's not a good effect on your mental
fitness and health to suppress your
emotions obviously from what we have
discussed today uh you are very
traumatized and and hurt individual very
insecure you lack a lot of confidence
um where do you think all of that comes
okay
I'm traumatized her individual who lacks
confidence yeah extremely insecure and
in denial of the reality she lives why
would I if I lacked confidence why why
would I be online all day
okay why wouldn't I just like not do
that yes Bill tell me so why are you
online if you're so scared if you are so
insecure
if often you call yourself to sleep but
deny it I don't I don't even remember
the last time I cried life is good
life is good you keep repeating life is
good because you think that comes from I
mean you keep repeating trauma where
does that come from
it comes from being human it comes from
the fact that you hate yourself
from your inability to accept your body
to the point that you will not even
start your own your own only fans
account
um I think that you know saying that you
are 5 out of 10 is completely
unrealistic and that's where I empathize
with you and I want to help you because
a woman like you shouldn't be giving
yourself a 5 out of ten it should always
be a 20 out of 10. you're a bad girl
boss and it is not fair on
yourself to treat yourself with so much
hate oh
so wait let me get this straight
I have to rate myself a 20 out of 10 to
have self-confidence
yes I believe that the last time we
checked the statistics and the research
points out that even a 20 out of 10 for
a boss pitch in 2023 is a relatively low
and humble score
okay 20 out of 10 is a humble score yes
Bill do you not believe you deserve 20
out of 10. oh you clearly has yourself I
didn't even know that was on the scale
called being realistic it's called
having high standards high expectations
and loving oneself do you have a problem
with loving yourself though
now okay
do you believe that you say no Allah is
that part of your denial uh I just think
I just think it's the answer to the
questions
okay you still you seem quite resistant
to to to to to the experience why do you
think that is
I'm just trying to answer honestly
okay do you lie a lot pal
no
okay I mean
sometimes everyone lies sometimes but
not not a lot a normal amount of lying
showing early signs of compulsive
lion okay bro I mean my my initial
analysis is one that is very much
um
is very much concerning it's alarming
for me is troubling as you can see I've
spent this entire session listening to
your problems understanding where your
traumas come from and I think that you
know you need to stop holding yourself
back you need to click your fingers a
little bit more perhaps wear more makeup
and think about showing more skin so
that you can get more validation from
men okay wait wait so you want me to
take off my clothes wear more makeup and
go like
yes yes so that you can fit into the
normal expectation of a woman in today's
society and the fact that you continue
to fight against what is your woman
your woman in nature is extremely
concerning Pearl
um I think we may have to consider some
medication after this medication I am
very worried after one session well I'm
very worried about you you are clearly
experiencing some serious delusion like
I said self-hate insecurity
um
are you a caper
yeah okay are you ready to love yourself
bro
sure amazing tell me what are the three
main things that you've learned about
how much you hate yourself today that
I'm a narcissist yes
I need to take off my clothes and I need
to call myself a 10 out of 10. yes
see the first the first step into
solving your problem is acceptance
narcissism yes be more confident and
accept your body show more but if I'm a
narcissist then wouldn't I need to do
less
no pearl
no Pro right now you need to do more
right now Pearl you need to take take
self-love to the maximum put yourself
out there in a way where people will
love you what is self-love self-love
means uh wearing makeup changing
yourself to be more accepted by others
to be more loved by others to fit into
the image of other spell to be able to
call for men's attention without having
to say a word but using your body using
your skin your flesh and your beauty
okay
so I need to get naked
to love myself have you considered a BBL
before Pearl
um no I've never considered a BBL and
why is that
I was happy with the body I got okay
denial and badly this mofia okay Pearl I
think I think you've made a great
progress today how'd you feel
fine do you love yourself more
about the same not the same okay
don't worry we will increase the amount
of sessions that we will have and
eventually we'll reach a point where you
will be able to accept who you are and
truly understand that you know what you
call the haters they are simply people
that care about you they know you and
they want the best for you
so I should I should care about the
haters yes we should I should I should
get a BBL yes and I should
um take off my clothes and start only
fast do you not want to be like
everybody else
no okay rebelling against fitting into
societal structures
um
I think that this comes from your
childhood perhaps but we'll have to go
into more detail with that
um is there anything else that you would
like to discuss whilst we still have
some time
not really no okay
the clock has just been taken down it's
gone so fast no I know you have fun and
flies it's just been so awesome yeah
okay Pearl um I'll send you an invoice
uh after the session okay
um and and I'll send you how many
sessions we'll be needing I know
initially I said 20 but after really
carefully analyzing your profile
understanding how you feel about things
I think you might need an extra five to
ten more
um Pearl thank you for taking the step
to know yourself and to accept yourself
and for being so open-minded and well
done for not crying I know that
sometimes you are holding your tears
back composing yourself which is great
but I'm not sure if it's healthy you
need to cry more
I'll work on that okay I'm going to give
you a quick prescription uh doctor's
orders
um I'm going to prescribe
more makeup
uh shorter skirts
and an only fan subscription okay once
you have done all of this when you come
back for the next session I'm sure
you'll feel a lot better A lot more love
for yourself and I'm sure everybody that
watches you at home will love you a lot
more Pearl okay
thank you you're very much welcome I'm
so excited to see you again Pearl all
right
I'm so proud of pearl I think she has
done brilliantly to take the first step
into coming to therapy from my notes she
needs a lot of help she needs a lot of
help and a lot of validation but we're
working to get her to really know her
true self to stop denying how unhealthy
and mentally and fit she is at the
moment and hopefully with some more body
a little bit more sassiness and a little
bit more sexiness will get her to a
level where she'll be loved by everybody
because obviously that's what she's
looking for I'm very excited to see what
comes next remember 500 pounds a minute
we've got 25 more sessions thank you
that was the dumbest I've ever been
to in my life
I mean this I could say I love my
father and she'll say why do you hate
men
like oh the your dad yelled at you he's
too controlling it's like
where did they get these for
therapy where do they get them like it
doesn't it's like it's like they breed
they go to college and they just breed
these crazy ladies to talk to me
oh
I was into now because she refuses
refuses to understand how traumatized
she is from her relationship with her
father giving her unhealthy expectations
of men and relationships with between
men and women to her needs to have
friends by going to do sport to her lack
of self-love and clear self-hate because
of her relationship with food because
she loves food she hates fat people so
yeah um I'm concerned about Pearl and I
really hope that I can help her she
really needs it never okay let me get
this straight This Woman This Woman
sad
um your homework is to cry more
starting only fans
take off your clothes
and rate myself a 20 out of 10. and
that's going to give me confidence and
make me not a picket
where do they find these women
where do they find like oh oh let me let
me start an only fans let me just
embarrass my entire family and friends
let's start a freaking only fans I think
uh that is the minimum required to be
able to straighten out all the Kinks of
trauma that Pearl clearly has not only
witnessed but really been through
herself from the emotional exploitation
and financial exploitation from others
especially men because obviously she did
say she brought her boyfriend a watch
for her for his birthday and she has
paid for things to also the fact that we
need to get her controlling impulsive
controlling Behavior under control I
think that is going to be a big step for
well she likes to tell people what to do
and uh that is a massive problem I hope
uh to get Pearl to perhaps retract some
of the comments I.E women should have
vote that is the most clear and obvious
expression of her self-hate and lack of
self-acceptance so we hope to reverse
this process and really get her to
understand that she's a bad girl she's a
bad B and and if she wants to start her
only fans it's just a matter of her
going to create her account
um I say that therapy this is the dumb
this is the worst afternoon I've ever
spent in my life
I I want a refund for my time I think I
should be paying for what I you just put
me through I why did you give me Janelle
denelle was the craziest woman from our
show
and you you had her be a therapist to me
really
yeah
sure for ten thousand likes we can do a
second session but I want to be vent
mode I want I want a caramel latte and
to be venmo for my time
[Music]